STARTING THE INTEREST OF TIME-
WE HAVE SOMEBODY WHO'S
PRESENTING AND I'VE- HELD HER
UP A COUPLE OF MINUTES SO. I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND BEGIN. A
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME I'D
LIKE THE CONVENIENCE ON LAND-
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BEFORE
WE MOVED IT TO AND I WANT TO
SAY A COUPLE HOUSE KEYS KEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OUR FIRST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT IT WILL BE
STEP IN AND OFFER SOME REMEMBER
CERVANTES TODAY THANK YOU AND
WELCOME WHEN HE ARRIVES. AND
THEN I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BRIAN AND
WEBER WHO'S BEEN APPOINTED TO
COMMITTEES OF CONGRATULATIONS
WELCOME AND A BIG ROUND OF
APPLAUSE ARE OUT FOR YOU. I'LL
MAINTAIN THE DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING HAS HAS BEEN CUSTOMARY
AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTED MAYBE REMOVE THE
CHAMBER- OR- REMOTE MEETING
ROOM SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR-
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. FINALLY WE
ARE PARTICIPATING IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES HERE THE CHAMBER AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF PEOPLE- IN
PERSON TODAY WE ALSO HAVE A FEW
OPTIONS FOR A WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. AND I WILL CONTINUE AS
IS CUSTOMARY UNDER OUR-
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE READ-
SOME NOTES HERE. IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE CHAMBER WITNESSES-
MAY MAKE THE USE OF REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED ON
THE NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL.
FOR CALLING WITNESSES WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL- THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING NOW REPEATS. THREE
TIMES FOR THE SAKE OF IT. AND
AS WELL AS THE ACCESS CODE
THREE TIMES. WHICH IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. 1-576-928-9578
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX. TWO THREE
SEVEN TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN AND VIOLENT TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
INFORMATION. ON THE WEBSITE OF
THE ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE AS WELL AS THE TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL TESTIFYING.
ON AT N. IT WOULD BE A IT WOULD
BE BETTER IF YOU CALLED IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION. REMAIN ON THE
LINE AND YOU WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOUR CALL TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE THE
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN ALSO.
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO SIXTY
SEVEN HOW REPEAT THAT ONE MORE
TIME. NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE
NINE. TWO SIX. THREE SEVEN. AND
OUR TEAM WILL BE THERE TO HELP
YOU. WE'RE ALSO EXPRESS-
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY- TO
THE THROUGH THE POSITION PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND
AS A HIM FOR ANYBODY LISTENING
I WOULD TURN DOWN YOUR TV. OR
YOUR COMPUTER ASSEMBLY SO THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FOCUS ON THE
PERSON TELLING GOOD TALKING TO
YOU AND ASK YOU TO COME ON
BECAUSE THERE IS A DELAY. AND
NO ONE TO MISS THAT. I AM WE
HAVE WHAT WE ARE DOING TODAY IS
WE'RE HAVING FIVE MEASURES ON
THE AGENDA TO OUR A CONSENT.
ITEM ONE WILL BE S. B. ON
CONSENT CALENDAR BECAUSE BE US
OF SEVEN FORTY THREE. AND ITEM
THREE WILL BE S. B. FIVE EIGHTY
NINE AS WE PROCEED WITH THE
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
OTHER STANDS AT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE THAT WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN INTO. AN
EFFICIENT FAIR. HEARING
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE. FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON ANY
MEASURE PLEASE. BRIEFLY STATE
YOUR NAME POSITION AFFILIATION
ONLY. AND AFTER THE MAIN
WITNESSES I WILL HAVE TO
ENFORCE THAT- TO ANY SIDE ON
ANY BILL. I'LL ALSO ASK MEMBERS
TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE
MICROPHONE TO THE PUBLIC IN
HERE- BOTH YOUR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY AS
WELL AS YOUR VOTES- DO WE HAVE
A CALL. BUT WITH HOME. OKAY
THANKS WITH THE MESSAGE YEAH. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SANTIAGO HERE SANTIAGO HERE
PATTERSON. PATTERSON HERE
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HERE BENNETT. DAVIES DAVIS HERE
EDUARDO GARCIA. HOLDEN HELLO
RICK SILVA RODRIGUEZ VALLADARES
WEBER. FELDER'S HERE WEBER HERE.
BY LOCAL THIRTY I'M MEETING
BRIAN. BRANCH BRAND HERE IN TEN
YEARS. YEAH WE'RE A KIT WERE
CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE LET'S MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AYE THE MOTION
A SECOND. D. B. H. AND- THIS
DAVIS DAVIS. I WAS BROWN'S
AROUSAL IS A RIGHT IS DAVIS.
I'LL BE REPEATING THE NAME AS
MUCH AS I COULD BECAUSE
SOMETIMES IT. CAN CATCH HIM UP
THERE- YEAH THE FIRST THE
SECOND MAN'S LIKE TAKE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AN EXAMPLE YES
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB SEVEN FOUR
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
A HOUSING AND COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. ITEM
NUMBER THREE S. B. FIVE EIGHT
NINE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE TRANSPORTATION. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON AYE
PATTERSON I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI BRIAN BRAND
AYE BENNETT. DAVIES DAVIES I
EDUARDO GARCIA. HOLDEN HELLO
QUICKSILVER RODRIGUEZ
BALLADARES VOTERS I WEBER.
WEBER HI. REX SO I SEVEN NO
ZERO DOUBLES ON CALL. THE
DIRECTLY THE ITEM TO SB TWENTY
EIGHT- DISCOVER YOUR IF YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
SANTIAGO AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SB TWENTY EIGHT A BILL THAT
WILL ENSURE CALIFORNIA TWENTY
ONE YEARS INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CAN CLOSE OUR DIGITAL
DIVIDE PROVIDE ROBUST DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ALL
COMMUNITIES WHILE ENSURING NO
CALIFORNIAN FACES
DISCRIMINATION IN ACCESSING. IT
ACCESSING THAT DIGITAL NETWORK
FIRST I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SINCERE GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF WHO WORK
DILIGENTLY WITH MY STAFF ON THE
RECOMMENDED COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
I WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS SET
FORTH IN THE ANALYSIS. FIRST SB
TWENTY EIGHT PUT STATE ASSETS
TO WORK IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRES
THE CPUC DGS THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY CALTRANS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES TO
INVENTORY STATE RESOURCES THAT
CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AT
MINIMUM DOWNLOAD SPEEDS OF A
HUNDRED MEGABITS PER SECOND. SB
TWENTY EIGHT PASSED THE STATE
TO CREATE A LICENSE AGREEMENT
SO THAT THE STATE CAN READILY
CONTRIBUTE THESE RESOURCES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT OF
ANY PUBLIC OR PRIVATE EFFORT.
IT TAKES A BROAD VIEW OF STATE
RESOURCES INCLUDING REAL
PROPERTY THAT COULD BE USED TO
SITE BROADBAND EQUIPMENT. RIGHT
TO RAISE IT COULD BE USED FOR
ROUTING FIBER AND EVEN WIRELESS
SPECTRUM THAT COULD BE USED FOR
BANDWIDTH CAPACITY. SECOND SB
TWENTY EIGHT AMENDS FOR THE
FIRST TIME A STATUTE CALLED THE
DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT. OF TWO
THOUSAND SIX OR DEFECT.
DIFFICULT PROVIDES CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
WITH THE STATE WIDE. TEN YEAR
LONG FRANCHISE LICENSE TO
DEPLOY A DIGITAL VIDEO
SERVICES. PRIOR TO DATE DIFFA
FRANCHISE HOLDERS HAD TO
NEGOTIATE WITH EACH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO GAIN SUBSCRIBER
ACCESS INTO SERVICE TERRITORY.
THIS REQUIRED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SEPARATE SEPARATE AGREEMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE I WAS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL AT THE TIME. THAT
WE HAD THE AUTHORITY IN THE
POWER TO NEGOTIATE. THEY'VE CUT
ENDED THAT REQUIREMENT AND
PROVIDED ONE INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE STATEWIDE LICENSE
WHICH INCLUDES DEFINED RULES
FOR ACCESSING EASEMENTS AND
RIGHTS OF WAY THIS IS WORTH. A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY AND
IT'S ONE FRANCHISE.
ADDITIONALLY DIFFICULT
FRANCHISEES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
REQUIRED TO BUILD THEIR DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN THEIR
SERVICE TERRITORY AREAS TO ALL
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT
DISCRIMINATION AND IN A
REASONABLE TIME FRAME. AND THE
STATUE CREATED DIFFERENT RULES
FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROVIDERS DEPENDING ON THEIR
TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER TO SPUR
COMPETITION SO THAT COMPANIES
JUST ENTERING THE DIGITAL VIDEO
MARKET PLACE WOULD REACH
FISSURED PERCENTAGES OF THEIR
SERVICE AREAS WITHIN JUST A FEW
YEARS. IT IS NOW BEEN FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS SINCE DIFFICULT
PAST SB TWENTY EIGHT REFORMS
DISCUSSED SO THAT ALL FRANCHISE
HOLDERS FACE THE SAME SIMPLE
REQUIREMENT TO NOT DISCRIMINATE
IN DETERMINING WHO HAS ACCESS
TO AN ADVANCED DIGITAL NETWORK.
IN OTHER WORDS SB TWENTY EIGHT
UPDATES THE STATUTE TO BE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AS TO HOW
ONE DIFFICULT FRANCHISE HOLDERS
TREATED COMPARED TO ANOTHER I
CONTINUES THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION AND TIMELY
ACCESS REQUIREMENTS. THE CPRE
C. HAS THE TASK OF REVIEWING
FRANCHISE FRANCHISEE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE FACT AS THE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS REQUIRE THAT HAS NOT
BEEN CHANGED SINCE THE CPUC
DOES NOT RECEIVE SUFFICIENT
SELF REPORTED DATA. TO KNOW IF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES IN A NON
DISCRIMINATORY. NON
DISCRIMINATE MANNER SB TWENTY
EIGHT REFORMS DIFFICULT
REQUIRING THE- GRANULAR DATA TO
BE REPORTED TO THE C. P. U. C.
SO THAT FINALLY THE STATE WILL
HAVE AN ACCURATE ACCOUNTING OF
WHO IS RECEIVING SERVICE. AND
WHO IS NOT GAINING THIS
ACCURATE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
NETWORK NETWORK MAP IS CRITICAL
CRITICAL FOR CALIFORNIA SO LET
ME JUST GIVE YOU A REAL QUICK.
EXAMPLE OF WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT INA IN A VISUAL FASHION
BECAUSE I'M A VISUAL PERSON I
LIKE TO SEE PICTURES AND I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THIS
AVAILABLE. FOR EVERYONE BUT
I'VE GOT SOME MAPS THAT I'D
LIKE TO IF YOU COULD SHARE- WE
CAN WE CAN PASS THEM OUT BUT.
SO. HARD TO SEE BUT HERE'S A
MAP WITH SOME NAMES OF SOME
CITIES AND THIS IS FRESNO AND
WE WORKED WITH- AN ORGANIZATION
IN FRESNO THEY GAVE US SOME
REALLY GOOD DATA. SO THAT THESE
COMPANIES HAVE COME IN AND SAID
THEY PICK THEIR SERVICE AREA.
SO IF YOU LINE UP THE NAMES OF
THE CITIES. HERE'S A SERVICE
AREA IN FRESNO EVERYTHING IS
COLORED. BASED ON DIFFERENT
COMPANIES RIGHT SO IT'S FRESNO
CLOVIS SINGER READ ME SELMA
KINGSBURG IT'S A IT'S A BIG
AREA SOME OF IT IT'S REALLY
EXTREMELY RURAL. THIS IS WHAT
THIS GIVEN THIS TO THE CPUC.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT IT LOOKS
LIKE EVERYBODY'S GETTING
SERVICE. WHEN IN REALITY. THIS
IS THE INFORMATION THAT IS
PRESENTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND AGAIN I'M LINING
UP THE CITIES AND THE PURPLE
SHOWS YOU WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS RECEIVING IN
REGARDS TO INTERNET SERVICE AND
YOU CAN SEE IT'S STARTING TO
LOOK A LITTLE BIT LIKE SWISS
CHEESE AND THE QUESTION
BECOMES. IN THIS PICTURE WHAT
ARE THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
NOT RECEIVING SERVICES. AND
THERE AND WHY ARE THEY NOT
RECEIVING THE SERVICES. WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS MORE
GRANULAR INFORMATION IN THIS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
TELL US WHO GET AND BY
HOUSEHOLD WHO'S GETTING THE
SERVICE AND WHO ISN'T BECAUSE
IF IN FACT THE IMPACT OF
PROVIDING THE SERVICE IS
DISCRIMINATORY AND IS LEAVING
OUT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WHICH IN
MANY INSTANCES MAY BE THE SAME.
THEN THEY HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHY.
THEY HAVE TO EXPLAIN MY ****
ARE PROHIBITED FROM FROM THEIR
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT FROM DOING
THAT AND THE REASON THIS
BECOMES IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE IF
WORD TOLD ALL THE TIME HEY LOOK
IF. WE'RE DOING A GOOD JOB HOW
DOES THE C. P. U. C. DECIDE HEY
WAIT A MINUTE YOUR FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT- SAYS YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING A LITTLE BIT BETTER
IN YOUR NOT SO WHY. SO THE
OTHER THING THE BILL DOES. IS
IT. IT PUTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BACK AT THE TABLE WHEN
DIFFICULT WAS INSTITUTED LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH CUT OUT THERE'S
NO PLACE IN A PROCESS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HOULD BE INVOLVED
BUT UNDER THIS BILL IT
BASICALLY SAYS WHEN THE C. P.
U. C. IS LOOKING AT YOUR
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT TO SAY DO
YOU GET ANOTHER TEN YEARS. THE
CITIES. GET TO LOOK AT THE
INFORMATION. OR THE COUNTIES
AND DETERMINE PUNE. I THINK
THEY'RE REALLY HITTING THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY BUT NOT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T. AND SO THEY NEED TO
BE AT TE TABLE SO THERE'S A
DISCUSSION AS TO WHETHER THE
DIFF COLLECTION SLICES. SHOULD
BE- INCLUDE IT SHOULD SHOULD BE
RENEWED FOR ANOTHER TEN YEARS
TEN YEARS IS A LONG TIME. AND
SO IT'S THIS IS. THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL IS BASICALLY TO CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GET
DATA TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
FOR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE
WITH A SEAT AT THE TABLE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHICH
COMMUNITIES ARE THE COMMUNITIES
ARE MOST LIKELY TO HAVE. ISSUES
WITH ACCESS- AND IT IT IT- IT
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
DIALOGUE AND A DISCUSSION ABOUT
WERE WE GOING TO DEPLOY. REALLY
LIMITED STATE RESOURCES BECAUSE
THERE ARE A MY BILL DOESN'T SAY
WHERE THE STATE RESOURCES OUT
AGO. BUT THERE ARE STATE
RESOURCES WERE I'M BETTER BEING
DEPLOYED THE ASSEMBLY HAS A
COUPLE OF GOOD BILLS THAT ARE
TALKING ABOUT. ABOUT THAT
SERVICE FUND- WE DON'T KNOW.
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO DEPLOY
THEM AND WHERE DO WE HAVE
HOLES- AND LET ME JUST SAY IN
ADDITION. THAT THERE ARE
PHYSICAL CONSTRAINTS. ON WHERE.
ACCESS CAN BE PROVIDED THERE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE BARRIERS
RIGHT THEY BECOME VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE WE'RE NOT SAYING THEY
HAVE TO DO IT. IF IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE THAT'S THAT'S PART OF
THE DISCUSSION RIGHT- MAYBE
THERE'S A WAY THAT THE STATE
CAN BE A PARTNER BUT BUT WE
NEED WE NEED TO KNOW AND WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
AND SO- THE KEY HERE IS THAT.
SB TWENTY EIGHT MAKE SURE THAT
OBLIGATIONS ARE BEING KEPT AND
THAT THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
ADVANCED DIGITAL NETWORKS IS
NOT BASED ON DISCRIMINATION OF
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THAT WILL
KEEP THEM FROM. THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY REQUIREMENT THAT
WE ALL HAVE INTERNET I MEAN YOU
VIEW SIDE DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHAT WHAT- HOW IMPORTANT IS
THIS SO THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS TODAY AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT- IS
KIMBERLY BALLOT THIS IS A
CONSTITUENT FROM THE TOFF
SENATE DISTRICT- AND JEFF NEAL
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. THANKS
CAREER AND JUST REMIND ME
WITNESSES WERE GIVING GOING TO
THE STATE FOR THE BEGINNING
FOUR MINUTES TO EACH SIDE. SOME
OF THE GO HEAD START- THE TIMER
AND I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A NUDGE
IN ABOUT TWO MINUTES TO ALLOW
FOR THE SECOND ONE IS TO DO TWO
MINUTES AS WELL. BUT IF YOU DO
GO OVER VERY FAR I HAVE TAKEN
AWAY FROM THE NEXT ONE- SIR IAN
MAY START ISN'T AS VALID AS AND
THEN- MISTER NAIL. MODERATOR
HAVE YOU PUT ON THE WITNESSES.
YES THEIR LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD KIMBERLY. YEAH AND
EXCELLING AT ALL IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY BY THEN I LIVE IN
CHESAPEAKE CALIFORNIA I'M A-
STUDENT AT THE RATE. AND
EVERYTHING FROM CLEAN SCHOOL
AND WENT TO ME BECAUSE IT'S A
LONG NIGHT I'M HERE TODAY THE
PART THAT SB TWENTY EIGHT RURAL
BROADBAND INDIFFERENT. REFORM
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AS
MANY OF YOU HAVE HEARD A LAST
YEAR DAY. MAY DISPARITIES THE
SENATE CALIFORNIA ONE HI MY BY
THE COLEMAN AND DAMAGE ACCESS
TO HIGH IN THE CONNECT AND.
UNTIL WE MEET OUR ONE OF THE
STUDENTS AT THE DOOR ALL KINDS
YEAH I THINK HI MY SCHEDULING
MORE THAN THE- OTHER FOR HOME
ENTERTAINMENT IT'S A GREAT. I
CAN'T REMEMBER. YEAH WE DO AND
I THINK WENT IN I ACCIDENT WHEN
THE HARD. IT CONNECTION WITH
THE ONE PROVIDED BY THE HIGH
SCHOOL BUT I CANNOT SAY THERE'S-
GET AT HOME THE ONLY INTERNET
ACCESS I HAVE WITNESSED. MARK
STONE LOCAL HOT SPOT. I FOUND
SOMEWHERE DAILY THIS NINE WHEN
THE NEXT BILL IS THE MOST
STABLE. SOMETIMES EVEN GOING
BACK THERE LATER WAKE UP AT THE
OR SIX THIRTY FIRST FULL. I
NEVER REALIZE YES I KNOW
PREOCCUPY NOTING. RIGHT NOW THE
MY BECAUSE HERE AT THE. SIX
PARKING HAVE BEEN ENACTED BY MY
YOU KNOW AND- NEW. I KNOW THAT
IT IF YOU AB RURAL STATION
HAPPY STATE. IN A TIME OF OUR
DAILY LIVES BECAUSE THE MARKET.
IT IS A ONE THAT IS PERSON
ESPECIALLY IT IS. ANYTHING KIND
OF STATE. WELL CAN FIFTY UNDER
THE FIFTEEN. IT WILL FOR
ADDITIONAL BURGERS AND ALL
INTERNET. FIFTY EIGHT. I KNOW I
HAVE A TWENTY EIGHT JUST
MERGING UNDER TWO MINUTES. THIS
VALVE THIS SORRY. AT IF YOU MAY
BE FOR THE END BUT I JUST WANT
TO KNOW DO YOU. WELL ARMED
IRAQI ARTIFACTS SB THING.
CALIFORNIANS WITH MAJOR WORK
PEOPLE RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED
SAKE. THANK. YOU FOR ME TODAY.
THANK YOU AND THE MISTER NEIL.
MODERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR CHECKING ON HIM. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JEFF
NEAL HERE BUT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY THANK YOU TO
SEND OUR COPIER- FOR OFFERING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THEM AS
SHE NOTED IT WOULD MAKE
IMPORTANT REFORMS TOO DIFFICULT
WHICH IS IMPLEMENTED FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO AND HAS NOT BEEN
SUBSTANTIVELY. WE EXAMINED ST
STE- DESPITE THE MANY CHANGES
IN TECHNOLOGY AND THE BUSINESS
MODELS THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN
THAT TIME. UNDER THE TERMS OF
DIFFICULT WHICH IS- THE CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS FOUGHT VERY HARD FOR
THAT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO- UNDER
THOSE TERMS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES WHICH
SERVICES TO PROVIDE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS EVEN WITHIN
ONE- JURISDICTION- INSTEAD OF
NEGOTIATING WITH COUNTIES AND
CITIES OVER THE TERMS OF
SERVICE. THOSE COMMUNITIES
NEEDS- MAKE IT TO DECIDE WHO
GETS SERVICE AND WHO GETS LEFT
BEHIND- SO SB TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD FIX THIS BY ASKING A
COUPLE YEARS SAID RETURNING
LOCAL AGENCIES TO A SEAT AT THE
TABLE ALL IT DOES IS A HOLD AT
LEAST COMPANIES TO THE STANDARD
THAT THEY FOUGHT SO HARD FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THIS IS THE
DEAL. THAT DAY- THAT THEY WANT
AND NOW THEY'RE OBJECTING TO-
BEING TOLD THAT THEY ACTUALLY
NEED TO LIVE UP TO THEIR END OF
THAT BARGAIN BAKER RETHINK
CREDIBLE REWARDS AND YET
DESPITE- DESPITE THAT THERE'S
STILL A NEARLY QUARTER MILLION
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WITHOUT- WITHOUT INTERNET
SERVICE THERE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
MORE IN SAN DIEGO AND RIVERSIDE
IN ORANGE OF PRESIDENT KENNEDY.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT THERE ARE
FIFTEEN MILLION PEOPLE AROUND
THE STATE WHO ONLY HAVE ACCESS
TO ONE BROADBAND PROVIDER. I
KNOW THIS BILL IS ABOUT ALL THE
DIGITAL COMMUNICATIONS NOT JUST
BROADBAND- BUT WE'VE WE'VE SEEN
JUST HOW. THE LINKS TO- WHICH
SHOULD ARRIVE AND THEY'LL GO TO
PRESERVE AND THEIR ABILITY TO
GET. THE SERVICES WHO GETS LEFT
BEHIND- AND- GET MORE THAN
NIGHT. ALSO THANK FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND- APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- NOW WE HAVE. TO OPPOSITE-
TESTIMONIES- FIRST MODERATE IF
YOU COULD HELP ME FIND- MISS
MCINTYRE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CAROLYN MCINTYRE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
ASK THE TWENTY EIGHT- IF I
COULD START MY TESTIMONY BY
MAKING CLEAR AND TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT GIVE
PASSED IS A LOG THAT FOCUSES ON
THE AUTHORITY FOR A COMPANY TO
PROVIDE VIDEO. CABLE AND VIDEO
APARTMENT EVERYTHING NOT ALL
I'VE BEEN THROUGH THE PROVISION
OF BROADBAND SERVICE IT DOES IN
FACT GOVERN WHERE THE COMPANIES
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THEIR VIDEO
SERVICE WE KNOW THAT THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO
ACCEPT. WE WOULD LIKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
REVIEW THOSE AMENDMENTS HOWEVER
WE NOTE THAT WHILE THERE IS A
AN AMENDMENTS THAT ATTEMPTS TO
LIMIT THE STATUTE TO BE A
PRIORITY THAT IS GRANTED TO THE
STATE. BY THE COMMUNICATIONS
THAT LANGUAGE THAT WOULD TOLD
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBIT A STATE
ENTITY FROM ATTEMPTING TO THAT
RATE- WAS NOT REINSTATED IN THE
LEGISLATION I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THE BILL DOES IN FACT
ALLOW THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AS THE ISSUE ARE AT
THAT VIDEO. FRANCHISE TO IMPOSE
THE BUILD OUT REQUIREMENTS YET
IT FAILED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION SITUATIONS WHERE
A COMPANY NEVER INTENDED TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THAT AREA AS
IS THE CASE FOR ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS. IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA
AND THE STATE OR AND TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN A
COMPANY IF I'M ABLE TO OBTAIN.
THE NECESSARY PERMITS. YEAH CAN
BETTER IS A OF THE LAW AND IT
HAS BEEN. FROM THE PER THAT
ATHLETES EIGHT IMPORT. THE
AUTHOR HAS TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE REPORTING OF DATA TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION FOR
PURPOSES OF ENSURING THAT
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE AS TO
WHERE BROADBAND SERVICES
AVAILABLE. I KNOW THAT THAT WAS
PLACED IN A SEPARATE SECTION
AWAY FROM THE DESK OF
PROVISIONS YES. IT ONLY WOULD
REQUIRE DISTAFF FRANCHISEES TO
REPORT THAT INFORMATION TO THE
COMMISSION AND I WANT TO BE
SPECIFIC BUT SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION NOT ONLY INCLUDES
WHERE WE PROVIDE CARE METHOD
BUT THE SPEED AT WHICH WE
PROVIDE CARE WITH THE COCKPIT
WHICH WE PROVIDE THEM WITH. A
LOT OF BUSINESS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION YET IT IS ONLY
LIMITED TO ONE TYPE. INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER DOES THE FACT
THAT ALSO HAPPENED TO PROVIDE.
VIDEO PARAMEDIC- IN TERMS OF
REPORTING I DON'T SEE HOW THAT
WOULD IMPROVE UPON WHAT THE
SENATOR STATES HER GOAL IS
WHICH IS TO HAVE ACCURATE
MAPPING I WILL BROADBAND
FACILITIES ARE AVAILABLE AND-
WHAT. ARE SEEN. BY THE
COMPANIES THAT WE HAVE POSTED
BAIL AND. WE REQUEST YOUR NOW
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISSPENT ARE
NOW WILL BLOOM. ASIDE PRIMARY
TO AND PHONE- MODERATELY. YES
THEIR LINES ARE OPEN. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MA'AM. BUT THERE. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO AND
MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF
OF KEEP CELL ANTENNAS AWAY THE
STATE SHOULD BE AWARE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGES OF WIRED
INTERNET ACCESS OVER WIRELESS
CABLE COMPANIES HAVE A FEDERAL
FRANCHISE TO OPERATE AND THIS
BILL ATTEMPTS TO CHANGE THE
TERMS OF THAT FRANCHISE THE
STATE CANNOT DO THAT THE BILL
ALSO THREATENS TO TAKE AWAY
THEIR FRANCHISE UNLESS THEY
COMPLY WITH CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS. YOU CANNOT DO
THAT EITHER. THE STATE POLICY
SHOULD BE THAT ANY COMPANY WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO FIBER OPTIC
CABLES. BOB SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE SERVICE USING THOSE
CABLES. THAT WOULD GIVE THEM
THE INCENTIVE TO LAY THOSE
CABLES THIS BILL FAILS TO DO
THAT. IF THE STATE GOAL TO
ENABLE UNIVERSAL HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ACCESS YOU DON'T WANT
TO DO THIS BY WIRELESS.
ACCORDING TO THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF THE TREASURY
RULES FOR FISCAL RECOVERY FUNDS
THIRTY ONE CFR PART THIRTY FIVE
THIS IS CALLED CORONAVIRUS
STATE AND LOCAL FISCAL RECOVERY
FUNDS- PAGE SIXTY NINE. IT SAID
THE INTERIM FINAL RULE PROP
PROVIDE THAT ELIGIBLE
INVESTMENTS IN BROADBAND ARE
THOSE THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES MEETING
ADEQUATE SPEEDS. AND ARE
PROVIDED TO UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES. UNDER THE INTERIM
FINAL RULE ELIGIBLE PROJECTS
ARE EXPECTED TO BE DESIGNED TO
DELIVER UPON PROJECT COMPLETION
SERVICE THAT RELIABLY MEET OR
EXCEED SYMMETRICAL UPLOAD AND
DOWNLOAD SPEED OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION. MEGABYTES PER SECOND.
WIRELESS CANNOTDO THAT ONLY
WIRED CAN. ALSO FROM THIS
TREASURY REPORT I QUOTE EVEN IN
AREAS WHERE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. BECAUSE IT IS
ON AFFORDABLE END QUOTE. THAT
ANSWERS THE OFFICE QUESTION OF
WHY CERTAIN PEOPLE ARE NOT
RECEIVING SERVICES MORE CELL
ANTENNAS WILL NOT CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. THE STATE MUST
BE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL THERE
SHOULD BE NO SPECIAL FAVORS FOR
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY. MAKE
YOUR CHOICES BASED ON THE
ACTUAL SERVICE AND ADVANTAGES
AND DISADVANTAGES. WIRELESS
RADIATION IS HAZARDOUS TO HUMAN
HEALTH CAUSE CANCER ACCORDING
TO THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH AND BECAUSE THIS HAS
BEEN AND I JOIN THE GENOMICS
MISTER GRAHAM. ANYWHERE NEAR
HOME. THE BEST WAY TO DELIVER
HIGH SPEED INTERNET IS WITH
FIBER OPTIC CABLES TO THE HOME.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE FOR THAT AND
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU MISTER
GRAHAM MERRIMENT APPRECIATE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- IN THE CHAMBER. AND
JUST NOTED ON TAKEN AT THE SAME
TIME TO SPEED IT UP WHO ARE THE
DIFFERENTIATOR TIONAL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. IN THE R.
T. S. MODERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE. REPORTER OPPOSITION
OF SB TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND ZERO PER OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT ON SB TWENTY EIGHT. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN REMINDING
EVERYBODY THAT ONLY STE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
HI THE FACILITY SALARY WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DAMON COMPLEMENT A
LEADER CALIFORNIA CITIES- IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO
BOTTOM LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS FALL YEAR
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
STANISLAUS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT LINE OF TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS A- GET ACT THEY'RE
ABOUT TO WITH THE CAL
ASSOCIATION SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND- THANK YOU NEXT
TO ALLOW OF A TWO YEAR LONG IS
OPEN. ON THE ALLOWED ON BEHALF
OF THE CAL AT CHOLISH AND THE.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO A LINE
OF THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS VERONICA
AVAILABLE CREWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FORD ACTION FUND
IN SUPPORT INTO YOUR. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
THE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ERICA HOPPING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA GO TO LINE OF
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE COUNTY SANTA
CLARION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN OCTOBER TO A LINE
OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHEN MEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ
WITH CORPORATE AND PARTNER ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHARE NUMBERS
NEEDS ALL OF ON BEHALF OF
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS UP
CLOSE TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE OF TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
LUCY SALCEDO CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE LINE
OF SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF
OF CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS
AND TELCOM AND- SINCE TAKING
TODAY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THOSE AMENDMENTS AND-
HOPEFULLY BEING ABLE TO.
QUESTION. THANK YOU WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO A LINE OF THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ANDREA BALL AND THE
HOUSES TO CLIENTS AND SUPPORT.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU AND
ACCESSIBLE TO LINE OF TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU KNOW TAKE IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE IF THERE'S
ANY- ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES I'M
SORRY FIRST I APOLOGIZE. THIS
ORDER BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH TO DO BOTH TBH
DAYS OUT OF THE H. SO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK AND TAKING A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS- I THINK IT'S VERY
LAUDABLE TO HAVE A MORE
DETAILED MAPPING OF WHEREVER
PROVIDING VIDEO I THINK THAT IS
THE INTENDED GOAL OF YOUR BILL
AND I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
GOAL TO HAVE. A FINER GRAIN AND
UNDERSTANDING WHERE- THE VIDEO
SERVICE IS BEING ROLLED OUT I
DO HAVE- AND IT'S ONE OF THE I
THINK THE OPPOSITION WITH THIS
PRODUCT WE HAVE A PARTICULAR
EXAMPLE AND SEE DIEGO THAT I
HOPE YOU WILL ADDRESSING YOUR
MEMBERS FOR THE NEXT COMMITTEE
AND THAT IS **** COMMUNICATIONS
GOES THROUGH CORONADO DOESN'T
NEVER INTENDED TO HAVE ANY
PROVISION OF SERVICE ACCORDING
TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
CORONADO TO GET TO A MILITARY
BASE DOWN THERE. SO IN THE
DIFFICULT THEY SAY THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH ALL THE. CENSUS
TRACTS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GET
THEM. THEY NEVER INTENDED TO
BUILD OUT. THEY PROBABLY WILL
NEVER BUILD OUT SO I HOPE YOU
CAN GIVE ME TO MAKE THAT ON THE
LEFT IN YOUR NEXT COMMITTEE. IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A REAL
ISSUE. AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THEIR INTENT TO EVER SAY. THAT
WE WANTED TO BUILD OUT BUT YOU
KNOW IT IS GOOD THAT WE HAVE A
FINER GRAIN OF UNDERSTANDING
OF. WHERE VIDEO IS AND WHAT IS
INTENDED AND WHAT IS NOT
INTENDED SO I HOPE THE AUTHOR.
WILL CONSIDER THAT A MEMBER.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS. I THINK
WE NEED TO LOOK AT IS. WHAT WE
WANT THE CPUC TO AUTHORIZE. AND
I WOULD PROBABLY BE HESITANT TO
ALLOW SI PC. TO AUTHORIZED-
REGULATION OF RATES. FOR VIDEO.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT AND WHAT
IS YOUR INTENT ON THAT ISSUE IT
WILL JUST GO THROUGH THE CHAIRS
CUSTOMER. SORRY THROUGH THE
CHAIR. IS W. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- APPRECIATE THAT THAT THE
QUESTIONS- AT THE BOTTOM LNE
IS THAT IS THAT WHAT WE ASKED
FOR IS DATA IN THIS. IN THIS
BILL AND ONE OF THE DATA POINT
IS THE RATE CUT BUT WHAT THEIR-
WHAT THEY'RE CHARGING ALONG
WITH OTHER INFORMATION IT'S
NOT. AT THERE'S NO ATTEMPT TO
REGULATE IT AND TO SAY HERE'S
WHAT YOU CAN DO AND WHAT YOU
CAN'T DO THAT IS NOT PART OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. AND THE
FINAL QUESTION- I DO HAVE AN
ISSUE AROUND. I UNDERSTAND WE
WANT TO SEE IF YOU SEE TO HAVE
THIS INFORMATION SO WE HAVE.
MORE GRANULAR PICTURE. OF WHERE
VIDEO IS BEING USED OR NOT USED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
PRIVACY AND CONFIDENT ENOUGH
PRIVACY CONFIDENTIALITY- TO.
GIVING TO SEE IF YOU SEE THAT
INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE
NORMALLY YOU USE A RANGE OF
SPEEDS RATHER THAN A SET SPEED-
AND THAT IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THINGS VERY. AND THIS VARIAION
OF PROVISION OF SERVICE SO I
WOULD HOPE IN THE FUTURE
AMENDMENT YOU WOULD BE
CONSIDERING- THE CONFIDENTIALLY
OP THE CONFIDENTIALITY ASPECT.
OF THOSE SPEEDS FOR CONSIDER A
RANGE THAT CAN BE GIVEN SO TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO LIABILITY
ISSUES IN THE FUTURE. TO THE
CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THAT- THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL IN REGARDS TO
THE- THE RANGE OF THE SPEECH AT
THE SPEEDS- OBVIOUSLY THE SPEED
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE- IF YOU
ARE IN I'M ABLE TO DO- ZOOM
MEETINGS OR YOUR KIDS ARE AND
IF- AND UNABLE TO. ACCESS THEIR
EDUCATIONAL INFORMATION BECAUSE
THEY THEY'RE THEY DON'T HAVE
THAT THE HIGH SPEEDS NECESSARY
FOR THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM SO- A
RANGE OF SPEECH MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE- AND- WE'LL TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT AND I DO
APPRECIATE HE WHOLE ISSUE OF
THE- PHYSICAL BARRIERS IT'S
NEVER INTENDED TO REQUIRE. THE
COMPANIES TO HAVE TO OVERCOME
PHYSICAL BARRIERS THAT CREATE
A- COST THAT IS- WHEN BEYOND
WHAT IS WHAT WHAT WHAT ONE
WOULD THINK IT'S REASONABLE SO
WE'RE VERY COGNIZANT OF THAT IN
THERE MAYBE LANGUAGE WE CAN ADD
THAT THAT- CLARIFIES OUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE SO APPRECIATE.
APPRECIATE COMMENTS. YES THANK
YOU AND I WANNA APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR IN THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL AND UNDERSTANDING
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC THE NEED FOR EXPANDING
ACCESS- I DO HOWEVER THINK THAT
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BILL'S DONE RIGHT AND
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
ACTUALLY COLLECTS- PRETTY
DETAILED DATA I'M DOWN TO THE
CENSUS BLOCK AND ADDRESS SO
ISN'T THIS INFORMATION-
DUPLICATIVE IF THIS IS A C. U.
P. C. IS ALREADY COLLECTING
THIS DATA OR IS THERE
ADDITIONAL DATA THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY NOT COLLECTING- AND
THEN MY OTHER QUESTION. IS
AROUND PREEMPTION IT'S BEEN-
BEEN BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
THAT THIS LAW COULD ACTUALLY-
IS IT'S MOST LIKELY PREEMPTED
BY FEDERAL LAW SO HAS
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL WAITED ON
WHETHER OR NOT- THIS IS LEGAL
AND WILL IT BE CHALLENGED IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO DO IS HAVE THIS-
LEGISLATION AT YOU HAVE AND
HAVE TO PUT RESOURCES IN- TO
LEGAL- THE LEGAL. ACTION ON
THIS BILL. THROUGH THE CHAIR.
YEAH YOU MAY ANSWER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS I APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH ON THE ISSUE PRESENT
PREEMPTION- YES LEAD COUNSEL
HAS LOOKED AT THIS AND THEY ARE
VERY CAREFULLY CRAFTED THE
LANGUAGE THAT WERE THAT WERE
USING- IT DOESN'T KEEP YOU FROM
GETTING SUED. BUT AT LEAST I
FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT WHAT
WE'VE TRIED TO DO IS TO THREAD
A NEEDLE THAT THAT'S VERY FINE-
AND- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOES VERY- REGULATORY PROCESS
AND WE DO OURS AND THEY'RE FOR
DIFFERENT SERVICES ENTIRELY.
AND SO WHAT WE FOCUSED ON THE
ON THE ON THE CPUC- AND THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING- ASPECT OF-
OF THE- SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED- YOUR OTHER QUESTION-
I HAD TO DO WITH DATA SO LET ME
JUST SAY THAT- IS THAT THE FORM
IN WHICH THAT THAT THE FORM IN
WHICH THE DATA IS PROVIDED IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THE DATA
THAT THE CPUC IS GETTING RIGHT
RIGHT NOW IS- IN A IN A FORMAT.
THAT GIVES YOU AN IDEA OF WHAT
IS THE WHAT IS THE SERVICE AREA
THAT THAT PARTICULAR COMPANY IS
INTENDING TO SERVER TO SERVER
AND SO THE FIRST MAP THAT I
SHOWED YOU- AND I CAN GIVE YOU
MY COPY OF IT SO YOU CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT IT IS THE SERVICE AREA
THAT THEY DECLARED AND IT IT'S
NOT VERY GRANULAR IT'S VERY-
BROAD AND WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS OKAY YOU'VE GIVEN US THE
SERVICE AREA. THAT YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE TO BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU'RE
PROVIDING THE SERVICE THERE ARE
NOT SO SHOW US THE DATA BECAUSE
YOU HAVE IT AND YOU GIVE IT TO
THE FCC SHOW US THE DATA IN A
FORMAT WHERE WE CAN WE CAN DO
AN OVERLAY AND WE CAN SEE WHERE
ARE YOU ACTUALLY GIVING SERVICE
AND WHERE HAVE YOU SAID YOU
WANT TO BUT YOU HAVEN'T YET.
AND THE REASON THAT BECOMES
IMPORTANT IS THAT IF YOU'VE HAD
THIS LICENSE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
AND- AND IF THE AREA THAT YOU
HAVEN'T PROVIDED SERVICE YET
WHY WHY IT'S EXPENSIVE TO DO
BUILD OUT THEN THAT'S THAT WILL
GIVE YOU TIME IS C. P. U. C.
CAN SAY NUMBER OF THINGS BUT IF
THE REASON IS. IF YOU THEN DRAW
MAKE A MAP OF. THAT AREA AND
IDENTIFY THE AREAS WHERE THE AT
THE RATE OF POVERTY IS ABOVE A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE. AND THEY
OVERLAP COMPLETELY THEN WE GOT
A PROBLEM THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE GRANULARITY OF THE
INFORMATION THEY PRODUCE IT FOR
THE FCC THEY WE JUST ASKING
THAT WE GET THE SAME KIND OF
INFORMATION FOR THE PUC
BECAUSE WE'RE THE ONES THAT
GRANT THE LICENSE. AND THE
LICENSE REVIEW BECOMES
MEANINGLESS IF YOU DON'T HAVE
AN ABOUT INFORMATION TO BE ABLE
TO EVEN YOU KNOW MAKE IT IS A
DETERMINATION OF HOW WELL
THEY'VE DONE THEIR BUILD UP.
FOLLOW UP CARE. YEAH SO AND- IF
THIS IS ACTUALLY FOR THE
OPPOSITION- CAN THE OPPOSITION
SPEAK TO THE CURRENT- DATA THAT
THE C. U. P. C. COLLECTS
BECAUSE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT GETS A VERY GRANULAR IT
GETS DOWN TO THE CENSUS BLOCK
AN ADDRESS- AND I'M WONDERING
IF THE OPPOSITION CAN WEIGH ON
AND WHAT IS ACTUALLY PROVIDED
AND WHAT CURRENTLY THE C. P. C.
U. P. C. COULD PROVIDE. AND
HOPE THE MISS MCINTYRE STILL ON
MODERATOR COUNTY PLEASE FIND
THIS MCINTYRE. I'M HERE MISTER
CHAIRMAN. CAROL AMERICANS ARE
HOPING YOU CAN HEAR ME- I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
CURRENTLY RETIRED GIFTED
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION BASED ON DEFENSIVE
BLOCKS THAT WE INTEND TO
PROVIDE SERVICE. THE
INFORMATION THAT IS REQUIRED BY
THE BILL IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE GRANULAR THAN WE ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT. TO THE
COMMISSION OR TO THE FCC AND
THAT INCLUDES SPECIFIC RATE
INFORMATION BUSINESS
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION. AND IT
IS NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL IF
SINGLED OUT ONE INDUSTRY AND
REQUIRES US TO REPORT.
SIGNIFICANT BUSINESS
INFORMATION NOT CURRENTLY
REQUIRED ELSEWHERE AND DOES
NOTHING TO ENHANCE BROADBAND
MAPPING. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. I WOULD HAVE MISSED
DAVIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY- QUESTION THAT
BROADBAND IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST BIGGEST PRIORITIES WE
HAVE COMING UP I DO HAVE- A
COMMON IN A QUESTION THROUGH
THE CHAIR OF COURSE- RIGHT NOW
WHEN THE BIGGEST WE COULD SAY
BARRIERS- CONCERNS ON IS THE
DELAY WITH TRYING TO GET THESE
PERMITS THROUGH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND SO MY QUESTION
IS THAT YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT THE C. P. U.
C. TO ACCESS DIFFICULT- TO
BUILD OUT BUT IT REMOVES THE
CURRENT LAW THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW THAT ALLOWS US
CONSIDERATIONS SUCH AS-
DISASTERS INCLUDING ILDFIRES
OR AGAIN- DELAYS ON GETTING
PERMITS SO MY QUESTION IS- WHY
REMOVED- I THINK IT WAS SECTION
FIVE EIGHT NINE O. F. OF WITH
THE CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW AND
WOULD YOU BE IN CONSIDERATION
OF PUTTING THIS BACK SO THAT WE
COULD ACTUALLY MOVE THIS
FORWARD. ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT DELAYED
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT PERMITS
THANK YOU. FOR THE CARE. THANK
YOU VERY THIRD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION- I WILL I'LL TAKE
A LOOK AT IT I DON'T. RECALL I
DON'T REMEMBER ANY AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD ACT IN THE WAY THAT
YOU SUGGESTED BUT WE'LL TAKE A
LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT THAT
SECTION. AND IF IT'S BEEN DONE
IN ERROR WILL WILL FIX IT
OBVIOUS OBVIOUSLY I THERE'S NO
INTENT. TO STOP. THE
EFFICIENCIES THAT ARE PART OF
DIFFICULT. THERE WERE SOME THAT
WERE WRITTEN IN SPECIFICALLY TO
EXPEDITE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THIS- VIDEO CONFERENCING SO-
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN IN
STOPPING THAT. PRITCHETT YEAH
JUST TO CLARIFY WHY I DON'T SEE
THAT EITHER BUT THEY HAVE TO
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT IT BECAUSE
I THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT THE
INTENT AND I BELIEVE IS MISTER
RODRIGUEZ RIGHT. YEAH ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU CENTER FOR- A
BRING FOR ALL SEE THE
PRESENTATION YOU GAVE TO US IS
VERY EYE OPENING SPECIAL TO MAP
YOU PROVIDED- AS WE ALL KNOW
THAT THIS PANDEMIC IS REALLY-
TAKE US TO A DIFFERENT LEVEL
BUT- BECAUSE OF THAT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WE REALLY MUST LOOK
ATHOW DO WE FIND THE WAYS TO
EXPAND SERVICES. TO OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES- WELL ELECTED
I PLAN SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT YOU
CONTINUE WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION. AKHTER DRESSER
ISSUES AND HOPEFULLY I GET A
BETTER PRICE FOR EVERYBODY.
BUT- THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AND-
CONTINUE WORKING THEIR
OPPOSITION. THANKS THANK YOU I
BELIEVE THAT ALMOST SUMS UP ALL
THE COMMENTS OF THE GUN MISTER
VICE CHAIR. THE HELP YOU CLOSE
OUT. I THINK HIS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO THE SENATOR- FIRST
OF ALL I DO WANT TO. LET YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE. THE
EFFORT HERE- YOU HAD MAPS OF
THE AREA THAT I HAVE I WAS
MAYOR FOR EIGHT YEARS- AND
SERVE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE- HOWEVER I DO.
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS- WITH
THE BILL AND IT. NOT
WITHSTANDING THEIR TESTIMONY- I
REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL
LAW. THIS IS THE COMMUNICATIONS
ACT IT EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS
FRANCHISING AUTHORITIES FROM
REGULATING BROADBAND INTERNET
SERVICE. I HAVE REQUESTED AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED A LEGAL
OPINION FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE REGARDING
PREEMPTION AND EXPECT TO
RECEIVE THAT OPINION FORMALLY
AND IN WRITING SOON. BUT
MEMBERS- MY ENTIRE BUSINESS AND
BROADCAST LIVE WAS- IN RADIO
AND THEN TELECOMMUNICATIONS-
AND LOTS AND LOTS OF
INTERACTION. NOT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BASED ON THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS ACT I
HAVE ACCESS TO MY OWN- LAWYERS
IN THIS SPACE. AND HAVE ASKED
THEM. TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AS
WELL. THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT DIRECTLY
OR INDIRECTLY REQUIRING A CABLE
OPERATOR TO EXPAND BROADBAND
SERVICE AS A CONDITION OF THEIR
FRANCHISE. IS PREEMPTED. I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT I HOPE. THAT
WE CAN GET TO A PLACE. WHERE WE
BUILD OUT THE UNSERVED AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN. EIGHT
YEARS IN THIS LEGISLATURE. AND
AS VICE CHAIR OF UTILITY. AND
THEN WE SPLIT OFF AT THE AT TO
C. AND C. AS WELL THIS IS A
SPACE THAT I HAVE CONTINUED. TO
ASK THE QUESTION WHAT IS TAKING
US SO LONG TO FINISH IT. BUT
THERE IS NO PUBLIC GOOD. IN A
BILL THAT ATTEMPTS TO DO THAT.
IF IT INVITES LITIGATION. THIS
BILL DOES INVITE THAT
LITIGATION SO I'M GOING TO
RESERVE MY VOTE ON THIS BILL
UNTIL THE FORMAL LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL'S OPINION IN WRITING IS
PRODUCED. AND ALL RESERVE MY
VOTE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CONSIDERING OTHER LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL SO. THAT OPINION ON
THIS WE HAVE STRONG REASON TO
BELIEVE BASED ON MY CONTACTS
WITH THE INDEPENDENT- LAWYERS
YEAH- IN SPACE THIS SPACE THAT
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
THAT THIS IS PREEMPTIVE. SO THE
GOOD THAT WE TRY TO DO HERE MAY
VERY WELL BE OFFSET BY A
LITIGATION THAT IS EXPENSIVE.
TIME CONSUMING AND UP. MIGHT
HOLD UP THE EFFORTS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. SO I'M GOING
TO LAY OFF THE BILL. WHEN THE-
LEGISLATIVE COUNCILS OFFICE
PRESENTS ME WITH THE- FORMAL
WRITTEN OPINION IT IS CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE- HAD EVERYBODY ELSE
AND IN FACT I BELIEVE THAT THE-
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL- WE'LL OR
HAS. NOTIFIED YOUR OFFICE OF
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE IN THE
MIDST OF CREATING AN OPINION I
DO BELIEVE THAT WE OUGHT TO
SLOW DOWN A BIT. TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT WE HAVE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
LAWYERS WHO ARE SAYING THAT
THIS IS. A PRODUCTION ISSUE IF
WE GET A CONCURRING OPINION
FROM BUDGET COUNCIL I THINK
THAT OUGHT TO INSTRUCT. THE
BILL AND HOW IT MAY BE AMENDED
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU. YEAH
THANK YOU IN AND THIS IS WHY
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORKS
IS BECAUSE PEOPLE CONTENT
EVERYBODY CAN HAVE A DIFFERENT
OPINION AND BUT WHAT THEY THINK
IS THE BEST A RESULT I DO WANT
TO DRESS AND JUST REITERATE
THAT WE DID LOOK INTO THE
ISSUE- PREEMPTION IN WHAT WE
BELIEVE WE'VE- ROAD IN THE BILL
AS AMENDMENTS AT THE AUTHOR
TOOK ADDRESS THAT AND WE DID
WORK WITH LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL.
NOW AND I HAVEN'T SAID THAT
BROADBAND IS YOU KNOW IS
REGULATED- AND PREEMPTED BUT
THE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY- THIS
BILL WILL WOULD ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF VIDEO AND CABLE-
WHICH ARE SEPARATE. FROM
BROADBAND THAT THEN. AND I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THAT GRANULAR DATA WHICH IS FAR
AND ABOVE WHAT THE CENSUS BLOCK
DATA HASN'T AND THEY'VE BEEN
DEMONSTRATED BY. BY THE GRAPHIC
FOR OR MAP BY LAW BY LACK FOR
LACK OF BETTER WORDS- BUT ALSO
A REMINDER COLLEAGUES TO THAT
THIS IS WHY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO EXIST. TO CREATE
LAWS THAT ARE. THAT INVENTED
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA
WE JUST MEANT FOR YEARS- GOING
IN ONE DIRECTION WITH LAWS THAT
WE BELIEVE. I WAS EMPLOYED FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ONE
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
AND SOYOU GOT WE CAN CREATE
LONGER UNIQUE AND IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA. AT OR WHY WOULD WE
HAVE LEGISLATURE- BUT HAVING
SAID THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
THE AMENDMENT STRUCK HERE.
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES- AND I'M
HAVING SAID THAT I WANT TO ST-
THE ARCHER MAGNERS FONG. SURE
THE TICKET PLEASE MATT. MY
REQUEST IS AN OFFICIAL INFORM A
FORMALIZED SPECIFIED REQUEST.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE BILL AS
PART OF THAT THEY WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENTS. AND
IF IN FACT WHAT IS CLAIMED HERE
IS FOUND TO BE SUPPORTIVE. IN
THAT OPINION. I SEE TO THAT
POINT BUT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
AMBIGUITY AND UNCERTAINTY. I
HEAR THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE DON'T WANT
SOMETHING THAT IS LITIGATED.
AND THAT. YOU SAY THE
LEGISLATURE EXISTS WELL
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL. EXISTS AND
SO THIS IS A FORMAL BROAD.
SPECIFIED REQUEST AND THEY ARE
WORKING ON IT RIGHT NOW AND I
TRUST THAT THEY WILL BE FAIR-
AND- GIVE US THAT AS A GOOD
OPINION- THE QUESTION IS THEN.
DOES ALLEGE COUNCIL- HALF OF
THOSE PREEMPTION CONCERNS AS DO
THE PRIVATE LAWYERS AND I'VE
CONSULTED N. AS THE LAWYERS
FOR- SOME OF THE OPPONENTS.
HAVE DEMONSTRATED- AND SO
THAT'S WHY I AM LAYING OFF. I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
A PLACE WHERE. WE CAN DO THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT THE AUTHOR
SEEKS TO DO WITHOUT THE RISK OF
LONG PROTRACTED LITIGATION AND
I THINK WE INVITE THAT. IF
WE'RE NOT VERY VERY CAREFUL. N.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT
AND THEN JUST GO TAKE A PER
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I
DON'T GO BACK AND FORTH IT'S
NOT CUSTOMARY TO DO THAT- BUT-
AND I AND I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IN GOOD SPIRIT TO DO SO. I'M
OKAY WITH THAT. FIRST I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE- BEING ABLE TO. TAKE
A LOOK AT- WHATEVER RESULT
MAKEUP. BECAUSE WE ALL AGREE AT
THE END OF THE DAY THAT WE- WE
GO TO LET'S COUNCIL- FOR PEOPLE.
AND WE ALL TEND TO AGREE THAT
ONCE THEY MADE AN OPINION WELL
WE AGREE OR DISAGREE ACOSTA-
BUT KNOWING MY COMMENT IS THAT-
I WAS LOOKING TOWARDS- THIS-
TOWARDS- TOWARDS YOUR REQUEST
OF LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL WHAT I
WAS AYING. WAS THAT WHEN WE
WERE CRAFTING THE AMENDMENTS WE
ALSO- ASK LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
WHICH IS A VERY DIFFERENT THAN
A DOZEN OPINIONS LEGISLATIVE
pRESULT OF THE THURMOND. SENDING
BOTH CAN EXIST- IT WOULD WHICH
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING THAT BUT-
IN MY COMMENT ABOUT LET'S MAKE
LAWS WE DO MAKE LAWS YOU KNOW
IN THIS IS WILL BE HOSTED A
CALIFORNIA- I TO LOOK FOR
TODAY- TO THE TELECOM. AND LOOK
AT WE'LL GO TO MY CONSCIENCE-
BUT TODAY WHO WERE HERE BEFORE
VOTING ON A BILL WHAT WE
BELIEVE WE'VE WORKED ON IN THE
AUTHOR HAS SPENT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH OUR TEAM.
ADDRESSING DIFFERENT ISSUES AND
WORKING DILIGENTLY THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT ITEMS AND THAT'S WHAT
MY COMMENTS WERE MADE TO BE SO
THAT I AT LEAST ADDRESS THAT
YEAH WE DID WORK LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL IN OUR TEAM SPENT
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME- THE
RESPECTIVE THEY CAN HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION- AND THEN
DOES THE LEGISLATURE- WE
OFTENTIMES DO HAVE A DIFFERENT
OPINION WE'VE HAD A DIFFERENT
OPINION WITH THE L. L. AS WELL.
THAT'S WHY- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT WE VOTE THEY DON'T- TO
HAVING SAID THAT- WE WOULD NEED
A FIRST IN A SECOND- ON S. B-
TWENTY. TWENTY EIGHT SORRY MY
MASCOT STOPPED. I THOUGHT OUR
FIRST FIRST MISTER BENNETT.
SECOND SEMESTER OF BRINE- MAN
FACT THIS IS THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION-
INSPECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I REMEMBER TO SB TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION SANTIAGO. HI
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BRENT HI
BENNETT. SENATE AYE DAVIES.
DAVID IS NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA. IN ORDER GARCIA I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I HELLO.
QUICKSILVER. HER EX SILVA I
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I ABILITY
EARTH. VOTERS NOT VOTING WEBER.
WEBER HI. HIS EIGHT NO ZERO THE
BILL'S ON CALL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU REGARDS RACIST. RIGHT NOW
WILL MOVE ON THE ITEM FOR MR
MAGUIRE'S I DON'T HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF SEEING HIM OTHER
REAL. MISTER MCGUIRE WHENEVER
YOU'RE PREPARED TO BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SHARING GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS- IN THE DEVICE CARE I'M
HONORED TO BE WITH YOU AND I
WANT TO. POINT OUT- INTO THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR INTO HIS
AMAZING STAFF VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE ENGAGEMENT- IN FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL- MISTER
CHAIR OF COURSE I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY AND GET RIGHT
INTO IT TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
HECK THREE FORTY ONE DIES.
NUMBER ONE PROVIDES THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO CREATE BACKUP POWER RULES
FOR CELL TOWERS LAND MINE
OPERATIONS A CABLE PHONE
SYSTEMS I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
THOUGH THIS BILL DOES NOT TOUCH
THE CURRENT PC PROCEEDINGS ON
BACK UP POWER IN THE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
CLARIFY THAT. NUMBER TWO IT
MANDATES AT THE STATE OFFICE
EMERGENCY FOOD SERVICES SHARES
THE INFORMATION THEY ARE TO
RECEIVE FROM TELECOM COMPANIES
ON NETWORK OUTAGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THE REASON IS THIS
THE DATA IS CRITICAL THE PC IS
CHARGED WITH KEEPING THE
NETWORKS UP AND RUNNING AND
MAKING THEM MORE RESILIENT BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY. AT TO SEE THIS
INFORMATION WHICH MEANS THEY
CAN'T INSURE THE SUSTAINABILITY
OF THE ENTIRE TELECOMMUNICATION
NETWORK HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE AND WE ALL KNOW WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT. WE SITE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- WHERE WE HAD
A POWER OUTAGE TO BUCKLE IN AT
SPEAK NEARLY TWO MILLION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAD THEIR LAND LINE CELL PHONE
AND CABLE SERVICE- INTERRUPTED.
OUR PHONES THEY'VE NOW BECOME
OUR LIFELINES IS HOW WE KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND HOW WE ARE ACTUALLY.
RECEIVE EMERGENCY ALERTS. YET
UP UNTIL THIS YEAR. OUR CURRENT
TELE. SYSTEM ISN'T MANDATED TO
HAVE BACK UP POWER. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THANKS TO
THE HARD WORK I'VE YOUR CHAIR
AND MEMBERS IN THISROOM. THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE P. C. HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO ENSURE OUR-
TELECOMMUNICATION. NETWORKS ARE
MORE RESILIENT AND THAT WE KNOW
WHEN THEY ARE WORKING. THE PC
IS RECENTLY ADOPTED DECISIONS
FOCUS ON WIRELESS AS WELL AS
WIRELINE- BACKUP POWER IN AGAIN
THIS BILL DOES NOT TOUCH THOSE
PROCEEDINGS- AND WE TOOK A
MEANS IN THE SENATE TO BE A TO
CLARIFY THAT- TELCO COMPANIES
UNTIL WE TOOK LIMIT WERE
INCREDIBLY CONCERNED. THAT THE
BILL WOULD UPSET THOSE CURRENT
BACKUP PROCEEDINGS. NOW A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ABOUT
HOW WE GOT HERE AND I PROMISE
I'M GONNA WRAP UP- IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN VIA SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY LEGISLATURE
REQUIRED. TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES TO SUBMIT. AN OUTAGE
NOTIFICATION TO- YES WHENEVER
AN OUTAGE OCCURRED. IN LIMITS
THE- THE BILITY TO MAKE NINE
ONE ONE CALLS OR RECEIVE
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS. THIS
INFORMATION GOES A CALLAWAY
YES. NEVER MAKES IT TO THE P.
C. IN BECAUSE THE PVC IS
CHARGED WITH KEEPING. OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM UP
AND RUNNING IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL FOR THE UNDERSTANDING
WHERE THE WEAKNESSES IN THAT
SYSTEM EXIST. WITHOUT THE
INFORMATION SI PC MUST RELY ON
THE STAFF INITIATED REQUEST TO
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES.
THAT AT TIMES AREN'T FILLED.
FINALLY MISTER CHAIR- I WILL
SAY THIS SB THREE FORTY ONE
REQUIRE- YES. TO CREATE RULES
ON OUTAGE MAPS FOR
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS TO
REQUIRE THE PROVIDERS TO ABIDE
BY THOSE RULES. ENSURING THAT
THERE'S CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
BOARD. IT REALLY IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL MISTER CHAIR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS AND I'M GRATEFUL BY
THE WAY MISTER CHAIR FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT. BOTH
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AS WELL AS
CABLE- AND ENSURES TO SEE PC.
HAVE THE INFORMATION TO BE ABLE
TO KEEP OUR TELECOMMUNICATION.
SYSTEM UP AND RUNNING IT'S
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA.
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS TO
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION STATE SHERIFFS ARE
C. ARE SEEN TO BE WE HAVE. RAY
GUIDE ON THE LINE HE'S THE FIRE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF ONTARIO
IN PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL TO HAVE COREY SAYS
STILL ON THE LINE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME MISTER CHAIR. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
NUMBER TO GO TO THE PHONE
MODERATOR AND WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES- MISTER GUIDE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHIEF. CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. AND
THE MISTERS OF THE CELL IS-
FROM- CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. I JUST WANNA
REMIND YOU ALL THE WITNESSES
AND THAT WE'RE DOING FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE SUMMIT
GENTLY- NO CHIU AT ABOUT TWO
MINUTES. HI MODERATOR YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU IN OUR LINES
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS INCLUDING MY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ MY NAME IS
RAY GUY FIRE CHIEF IN THE CITY
OF ONTARIO AND THE PRESIDENT
ELECT OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. DISASTERS
AND POWER SHUT OFFS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
EMERGENCY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED
FOR BOTH RESIDENTS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS. WHETHER WE LOOK AT
THE CAMPFIRE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN UP IN PARADISE OR THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NORTH
BAY FIRESTORM GETTING THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE SAFELY EVACUATED IN
THE EARLY HOURS OF A DISASTER.
IS A LIFE OR DEATH AND ALL
FIRST RESPONDERS IN OUR
RESIDENTS NEEDS AND I'VE COME
TO EXPECT OUR PHONES TO WORK
ONE IS THAT HER STRENGTH. SB
THREE FORTY ONE WILL IMPROVE
OUR TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS
BY CREATING STRONGER OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS AND
THE CALIFORNIA BROKE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
OUTAGES AND KOCKUMS POWER
SYSTEMS. DURING THE POWER
OUTAGES IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN NEARLY TWO MILLION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAVE THEIR LAND LINE CELL PHONE
AND CABLE SERVICES INTERRUPTED.
BUT SMALLER OUTAGES OCCUR IN A
REPORT TO- YES DEMONSTRATING
WEAKNESSES IN OUR EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM BUT THE
CPUC HAS NO IDEA WHEN THEY'RE
OCCURRING. SB THREE FORTY ONE
WILL REQUIRE- YES THIS YEAR
COMMUNITY ISOLATION OUTAGE
INFORMATION WITH THE CPUC AND
REQUIRES THE CPUC TO REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON ACTION TAKEN
USING THE COMMUNITY ISOLATION
OUTAGE INFORMATION. THE CPUC
REGULATED TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE
BACKUP POWER BUT IF THE TELCOS
REPORT OUTAGES OF THEIR
NETWORKS TO THE O. TWO OH YES.
THE CPSC IS UNABLE TO FIND OUT
IF THAT OUTAGE OCCURRED WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
THREE FORTY ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. MISTER
TURNOVERS COREY CELLS ELLO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION-
HAPPY TO BE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FORTY ONE AND IN THE
SPIRIT OF BREVITY- IN YOUR
VALUABLE TIME I WILL JUST KNOW
THAT HAVING ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT NINE ONE ONE
OUTAGES IS VITAL NOT ONLY THE
PUBLIC BUT ALSO LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIRST RESPONDERS BOLSTERING
OUTAGE MAP REQUIREMENTS WILL
MAKE THIS IMPORTANT INFORMATION
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. ADDITIONALLY
ENSURING TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE CORPORATE
BACK ELECTRICAL SUPPLY TO
ADDRESS CHALLENGES IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE CONSUMERS CAN
COMMUNICATE ESPECIALLY IN TIMES
OF DISASTER AND FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE NOT IMPEDED FROM
DOING THEIR VITAL WORK SB THREE
FORTY ONE ALSO ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING PC IN
CALLAWAY US TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT BACKUP ELECTRICAL
SUPPLY RULES FOR THESE REASONS
CSSA IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT-
CENTER. MCGUIRE'S SB THREE
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
KNOW THE SHORTEST TESTIMONY AND
OUR WOULD BE TO DO THAT. AND
THEN- WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
TESTIFYING BY. PHONE MODERATE
IF YOU COULD FIND- MISTER
CARLSON OR MISS OR MISTER-
OROVILLE. MISTER MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS STEVE CARLSON- I'M ON
THE LINE- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CENTER MCGUIRE US STEVE CARLSON
FIFTY P. I. A WHERE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
EXTREMELY CLOSELY WITH SENATOR
MCGUIRE ON- ON THIS ISSUE FOR.
THE LAST THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AND THE AND CLOSELY AND IN GOOD
FAITH BOTH OF US- WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT THE ACT THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE- AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- SENATE MCGUIRE
IS TAKEN THEY HAVE ADDRESSED-
SEVERAL OF OUR ISSUES WE HAVE
PROVIDED- AT. A FAIRLY
COMPLICATED AND- I MEAN
COMPLETE SET OF AMENDMENTS TO-
TO SENATE MCGUIRE WHICH WE
CONTINUE TO- DISCUSS- WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK IT OUT SO
THAT IT'S WORKABLE- FOR THE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE TO
IMPLEMENTED- ON THE PROVISION
OF INFORMATION TO THE PC- WE-
TO MAKE SURE. THAT INFORMATION
IS DEALT WITH AS IT IS-
PROVIDED WHICH IS ON PUBLIC
SAFETY RELATED ISSUES. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT WITH- YES
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION
WHICH IS PURELY PUBLIC SAFETY
RELATED- THAT IT NOT BE USED-
ON THE BASIS OF SOME OTHER
REGULATORY PROCEEDINGS. I WOULD
THINK THAT'S A FAIR REQUEST- WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT TO OF
MAINTAIN THAT INFORMATION
CONFIDENTIAL AND WE TAKE THE-
COMMITTEE- THAT DID THE RIGHT
THING THERE. ANOTHER ISSUE-
WHERE THERE WE BELIEVE THERE IS
SOME INCONSISTENCY WITH THE P.
THINK THE BILLION PEOPLE ARE
EXPECTED TO THE BILL- WHERE-
THE- THE- PROVISION OF SERVICE
FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS WHICH WE
ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH THEM
WHICH IS PART OF THAT. THE UC
RESILIENCY ORDER- IS. BOB
APPLIED IN THE TEARS MORE TO
AND THREE FIRED. HERE'S BUT THE
BILL APPLY THAT BROADLY WE
THINK THERE'S AN CONSISTENT
THERE AND- WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT. FINALLY THE WAY
THE ISSUE IS DEALT WITH AT THE
P. YOU SEE ON THE RESILIENCY
ORDER IS THE PROVISION OF
SERVICE FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL APPEARS TO SUGGEST-
THAT IF WE'RE GOING BACK TO ITS
ORIGINAL IDEAS THAT EVERY CELL
SITE HAD TO HAVE. A SEVENTY TWO
OUR GENERATOR I THINK WE'VE ALL
AGREED THAT THAT'S NOT LIKE NOT
FEASIBLE BUT NOT NECESSARY-
CARRIERS BUT THEIR NETWORKS
TOGETHER. I'M MORE THEY HAVE A
MAIN COVERAGE SITE AND THAT
AFFECTED A PARTICULAR- ADJACENT
SITE GOES DOWN THEY CAN OFFLOAD
THAT WITHOUT HAVING TO HAVE A
GENERATOR ON EVERY SIDE. SO
WE'D LIKE TO AND I AM ADDRESSED
THIS ISSUE WITH THE- WITH THE
CENTER STAFF I WOULD LIKE TO
LOOK AT THAT ISSUE JUST SO THAT
THAT DOWN THE ROAD- THERE'S NOT
A- THAT THERE'S NOT A- AND
AMBIGUITY THAT SOMEHOW OR
OTHER. USING THE TERM BACKUP
ELECTRICAL SUPPLY BECOMES- THE
MATTER IN WHICH WE DO THIS WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT WAS
INTENDED BUT WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
FINALLY. WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS THIS IS BEING DONE
ON THAT STEAK ALL STAKEHOLDERS
BECAUSE HELP INCLUDING THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY. BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE- OF THE WORK- SO
FAR WITH LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THAT.
WOULD CENTER MCGUIRE- AS THE.
BILL MOVES TO ITS NEXT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS BECAUSE- WE ARE NOW MOVES
PUBLIC. HI ANY SUPPORT OR ON.
WITNESS IN THE CHAMBERS ANY
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. AND RTS
ROOM- MODERATOR ANY SUPPORT
HAVE ONE IN THE CHAMBER. ALL
AYE PA AYE I APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT- AND IT'S JUST NAME-
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
AND AGAIN I APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT SKIP. YEAH LOOK LET'S GET
THAT ON THAT- THAT WAS NOT THE
INTENT HE COULD HOLD ON. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHERS IN THE CHAMBER
THAT I MAY HAVE MISSED. I'LL
JUST REPEAT IT AGAIN ANYBODY
ANYBODY IN THE- RTS- IF THE
MODERATE WOULD NOW GO TO THE
PHONE- AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
A POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF S. B. THREE FORTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SB THREE
FORTY ONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS A DEMON
CONKLIN WITH THE WEEKLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
FOUR ONE. THANK YOU AN
EXTROVERT A LINE OF FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
YODER ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE
OF THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A
TIME YOU. CHAU NUMBERS NEED TO
LOG ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS ARE PROBABLY
LESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA BOTTLE LINE OF
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY THE SANTA CLARITA AND
THOUSAND OAKS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NET TO A LINE OF TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES BEING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS KARAGIAS ADDRESS
REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTROVERTED A LINE OF SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO
YOU HAVE A TIME YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS WHAT MUHAMMAD
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WILL RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WILL GO IN THE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND MISTER
BENNETT HAD- COUPLE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS
CHAIR- OF THE FIRST TIME LIKE
THANK OF THE SENATOR- FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL. AND
THERE ARE MANY DESTRUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA- THAT ARE WILL BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY- THESE OUTAGES- I
DO HAVE- TWO QUESTIONS- ONE
THIS BILL REQUIRES SEVENTY TWO
HOUR BACKUP OF ELECTRICITY-
HAVE FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS. OF THE BILL DOESN'T
REQUIRE THE CPUC TO CHANGE
THEIR EXISTING RULES ON THE
ISSUE- SO COULD YOU CLARIFY
WHAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING IS ON
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR- THIS BACK
UP INTO YOUR ONE TWO AND THREE
FIRE HAZARD AREAS. AND ALSO THE
QUESTION BROUGHT UP BY. THE
OPPONENTS TODAY ABOUT. THIS IS
A SEVENTY TWO HOUR BACKUP FOR
EACH TOWER OR- SO IF YOU COULD
HELP US WITH THAT PATIENT OR
THE PATIENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
A SENATOR FOR THAT THAT
QUESTION I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT SO LONG STORY SHORT LAST
YEAR WE ACTUALLY BROUGHT
FORWARD A BILL THAT WOULD-
IMPLEMENT SEVENTY TWO HOUR
BACKUP FOR. CELL PHONE TOWERS
NOT ALL BUT TO BE A TO KEEP THE
NETWORK RUNNING. BEING CANDID
THE BILL- DIED- AND THEN THIS
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION PICKED UP THE ISSUE
THEY ARE STUDYING IT IS WELL.
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AT TOWARDS THE END OF LAST YEAR
MANDATED SEVENTY TWO HOUR
BACKUP- FOR WIRELESS TOWERS IN
IN EARLY THIS YEAR THEY
MANDATED BACKUP FOR WIRELINE
AND CABLE- THEY TOOK A BIT OF A
DIFFERENT APPROACH IF I COULD
BE HONEST WITH YOU- THAN WHAT
WE TOOK. SO AB THE COMPANY
PUBLIC CHOOSE COMMISSION TOOK A
MUCH MORE AGGRESSIVE APPROACH
LOOKING AT ALL TOWERS- IS WELL
AS A CABLE EQUIPMENT. AGAIN
DIFFERENT APPROACH. OUTSIDE THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THIS BILL
DOES NOT TOUCH THOSE
PROCEEDINGS- NUMBER ONE
INDUSTRY. NCPC ARE ALIGNED ON
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE. SO OUR
BILL AND WE TO CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE TO SAY
THAT WE'RE NOT TOUCHING THOSE
CURRENT PROCEEDINGS. WHICH
MEANS- IN THE EXISTING CPUC
PROCEEDINGS ARE IN TIER TWO
TIER THREE. THAT'S WHERE THE
MANDATES WILL FALL FOR BOTH
WIRELESS AND WIRELINE BUT THIS
BILL DOES NOT TOUCH- THAT
PROCEEDING AND WE'RE TAKING- IN
WHICH MEANS I WILL NOT IMPACT
THAT OUTCOME. AND THE OTHER
QUESTION IS COULD YOU JUST AT
THE END OF DIESEL GENERATORS
ARE. ARE LIKELY TO BE THE BACK
UP AT THIS POINT TIME WHAT DO
YOU SEE AND WHAT DO YOU HEAR
FROM THE CPUC ABOUT EVENTUALLY
MOVING FROM DIESEL GENERATORS
SOMETHING MORE APPROPRIATE FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE. YEAH IT'S A
REALLY GOOD QUESTION THIS CAME
UP A LOT LAST YEAR AS WELL SO I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE
OUTGAINED GIVE YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE AND- IN FULL
DISCLOSURE ON A WORKING GROUP
THAT WE ALSO HAVE ESTABLISHED.
SO NUMBER ONE AND I DON'T EVER
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION BUT I'LL GIVE YOU MY
OWN EDITORIAL I BELIEVE THE
INITIAL ROLLOUT WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA SEE- BOTH FOR CABLE AS
WELL AT TELCOS WILL BE DIESEL
GENERATION REASON BEING IS.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE A LOT OF
TEMPORARY MOBILE GENERATORS
PUTTING THE COMMUNITIES- AND
IT'S GOING TO BE THE FASTEST TO
DEPLOY- WHERE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WANTS TO GO IS LOOKING AT NON
FOSSIL FUEL ALTERNATIVES. BUT
WHERE THEY'RE MOVING NOW IS
WITH SPEED IF WE HAVE ANOTHER
SUMMER IN FALL THAT WE HAD IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN- IT'S
GONNA HAVE HONESTLY WILL ALL BE
TO BLAME IN THIS ALONG WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION SIR
THEY'RE MOVING WITH SPEED AND
YOU'RE GONNA SEE EVOLUTION OF
THE EQUIPMENT. BATTERIES SOLAR
PANELS YOU NAME IT HERE IN THE
COMING YEARS BUT THE INITIAL
DEPLOYMENT WILL EITHER BE
TEMPORARY OR PERMANENT DIESEL
WASTE TRANSITION HERE IN THE
COMING MONTHS AND YEARS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU
SIR FIGURE IT OUT FOR THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. OR QUESTIONS. FACING
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE CASES TODAY
GREATLY APPRECIATED- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY BUT
I URGE THAT YOU WORK WITH
OPPOSITION- LOT OF THE CALLS I
GET WORD FROM SMALL COMPANIES
AND THEIR CONCERN. OF
LIABILITY- IN NOT HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY OR THE TIME TO
ACTUALLY- GO AHEAD AND- YOU
KNOW. PROVIDE THE- POWER NEEDED
IN EMERGENCIES SO IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE YOU KNOW MAKE SURE THAT
YOU TAKE THE TIME. OBVIOUSLY WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE- SOLUTION- NOT TO BE
FOR THE STATE BUT IT ALWAYS
GOES DOWN THE CONSUMERS WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THE SUIT
CONSUMERS ARE GOING TO GET HIT
WITH THE- INCREASE. ABSOLUTELY
SO- WE'RE WORKING ON
SPECIFICALLY. ON ISSUES RELATED
THIS BILL WITH BOTH- WIRELESS
WIRELINE ALONG WITH CABLE AS IN
THROUGH MY ROLE AS GOVERNMENT
AND FINANCE CHAIR IN THE SENATE
WE'VE ALSO BROUGHT TOGETHER A
WORKING GROUP WITH CABLE
COUNTIES AND CITIES TO TALK
ABOUT EXPEDITING DEPLOYMENT- IS
WELL SO VERY ENTRENCHED IN THIS
ISSUE AND YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL BE
WORKING AT HAND INSIST ON THIS
HERE IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO
COME. IN I WOULD LOVE IT IF YOU
WOULD LIKE WITH ACTIVE HERE TO
KEEP YOU UPDATED IF THAT WORKS
FOR YOU IF YOU WERE WEARING
GIANTS COLORS WHICH I'M EXCITED
ABOUT. SO THERE YOU GO. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AND IF
I'M NOT SEEING ANY OF QUESTIONS
I LIKE TO HAND OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR. YEAH SURE THANK YOU-
SENATE APPRECIATE- THE BILL AND
THE ATTEMPT HERE. I WANTED JOIN
MY- CALLING IN AND ASKING FOR
YOU TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER THE
ISSUES RAISED BY CTIA- BY THE
OTHER- PROVIDERS AND OPERATORS
HERE- THEY BRING TO THE TABLE-
EXPERIENCE THEY BRING TO THE
TABLE ABILITIES- WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE ENHANCE
AND FOSTER THEIR EFFORTS TO DO
WHAT THE PC HAS- INDICATED WITH
RESPECT TO THE BACK UP- AND SO
I'LL BE VOTING. FOR TODAY- AT
BUT AGAIN ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP
IN COMMUNICATION AND TRY TO
BESIDES THIS BILL AS IT GOES
FORWARD I THINK WE'RE CLOSE AND
I THINK THERE ARE SOME MEASURES
THAT NEED TO BE- BE ROUGHED OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SURVEYS
CHAIR- YOU HAVE OUR COMMITMENT
ALONG WITH THIS AND NEVER
DAVIES THANK YOU- AND I KNOW TO
SAY TO A C. T. I. H. CREDIT-
WERE WE WROTE CHALLENGES WITH
SELLING THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT. AND I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE CTIA MISTER CARLSON
HE IS LITERALLY ON A MONTHLY
SOMETIMES BI MONTHLY CALL TO BE
A DEVELOP. TWO NEW CELL SITES
IN KOGELO- WHICH- IS- IN RURAL
PART AND THEN JUST YOU KNOW
COUNTY- ON AROUND VALLEY
RESERVATION. IN SO- WE'RE
WORKING WITH- MISTER CARLSON ON
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE ALONG WITH
MANY OTHERS IN MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MADAM ASSEMBLY WOMAN-
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT WILL
CONTINUE. TO WORK OUT WITH AND
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU-
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR- YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
OVER THE YEARS. HAVE
CONTINUOUSLY. S. THOUGHT CAN
PROVE YOUR DISTRICT IN OTHER
AREAS LIKE THAT. I KNOW HAVING
SAID THAT WE STILL NEED A-
FIRST AND A SECOND FOR SB AT
THREE FORTY ONE AND NOW WITH
THE THEM. AND THAT WULD- IT
THIS BILL ENJOYS DO PASS- AS
AMENDED TO THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT MANY IN YOU KNOW
WHAT I MAY HAVE GOTTEN TO THE
VERY BEGINNING ASK IF YOU'RE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND I THINK WE AGREED ON
EARLIER. I GET I SAID I GLADLY
SAY ACCEPTANCE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOW WE MISTER BY WHOSE
FOR. WHO'S MADE A MOTION. MISS
WEBER FALCONS IF I IF I DON'T
HEAR THE MASS AT ALL SEE THE
OKAY AS A THANK YOU- MENTORSHIP
IS CALL THE ROLL. HADDENHAM
FOUR S. B. FOUR. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSAGE AMENDED TO
EMERGENCY MAY. SANTIAGO I
SANTIAGO PATTERSON PATTERSON I
BOERNER HORVATH. BRIAN BRENT HI
BENNETT. VENETI DAVIES DAVIES I
EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA
I HOLDEN HOLDEN I LOW.
QUICKSILVER. SHARKS SILVA HI
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I VOTERS
MILITARES I WEBER. WEBER HI
ISAIAH LEVIN NO ZERO THAT BILLS
ON CALL. VEGETATIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH RESEARCHER VERY
GRATEFUL TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU THINK IS RIGHT YOU'RE-
AND WE'RE LOOKING FO- SENATOR
WILL CLEAN THOSE CANAL. I DON'T
WITH CALLS OFFICE. YEAH
EXPENDITURES ON. THE RUSSIANS
OF. OKAY CAN YOU HOLD. I CAME.
YEAH.
CAN.
THE.
YEAH WITH THE.
HOW WERE YOU SEEN CHAIRS IN THE
RESTAURANT. I CAN- REPRESENT.
MISTER WILL GIVE. MR WILL. YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BEFORE YOU IS SB FIVE
FORTY SIX WHICH EXTENDS THE AYE
FOSTER PILOT PROGRAM AS PART OF
PUC'S BROADER LIFELINE PROGRAM
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT THE PC
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE CRUCIAL TO
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICES TO
FOSTER YOUTH. L. A. COUNTY HAS
A LARGE POPULATION OF FOSTER
YOUTH IN ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE
FOSTER YOUTH IN L. A. COUNTY.
RESIDES IN MY SENATE DISTRICT.
SO I'M VERY AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE FOSTER YOU
FACE IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA IS
VERY TROUBLING AND
DISHEARTENING. THE CHANCES OF A
FOSTER YOUTH GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL IS LESS THAN HALF OF A
NORMAL STUDENT. THEIR
GRADUATION RATE IN TERMS OF
GETTING A BACHELOR'S DEGREES
ABOUT 4% I KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS DOESN'T HAVEHARD
DATA. THEIR ESTIMATES IS THAT
UP 220% OF THOSE INCARCERATED
ARE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. WITH
THIS THIS AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES A FOSTER YOUTH WITH
THE PHONE WHICH IS CAN BE THE
KEY TO FAILURE OR SUCCESS IT
HELPS CREATES STABILITY IN
THEIR LIVES ALLOWS THEM TO. TO
CONNECT WITH THEIR FAMILY
MENTORS- SERVICES AS WELL AS-
DOING THEIR EDUCATION- WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE EXPERT
TESTIMONY IS CERITA **** CEO OF
THE AYE FOSTER PROGRAM. SECOND.
THANK YOU. THE BILL. MODERATOR
WE HAVE. TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SO I WILL ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
CERITA **** BUT I FOSTER. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE AYE PROCTER AND OUR
PARTNER SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
FORTY SIX AS A SENATOR WILK
SAID MY NAME IS SERENA **** I
AM THE CEO AND CO FOUNDER OF
AYE SOFTER AND A FORMER FOSTER
YOU. ACCESS TO A BAR RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS IS A TRUE LIFE
LINE FOR OUR USE THIS IS WHY I
AM PROUD TO SAY THAT THE I
TALKED TO BILLS FOR PROPERTIES
PROGRAM. IS THE FIRST AND ONLY
PROGRAM IN THIS COUNTRY TO
PROVIDE EQUITABLE RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS FOR FOSTER.
YOUTH AND IT TOOK SIX SACKS. BY
A TOTAL FIFTEEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN CALIFORNIA BOTH
TO USE WITH ACCESS. LAUNCHED
MID NOVEMBER IN TWENTY NINETEEN
IN JUST A YEAR AND A HALF THIS
LIFELINE PILOT HAS PROVIDED
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO FIVE TO USE. MEETING THE
NEEDS THAT 84% OF PILOT
ELIGIBLE PARTIES. WE ALSO
CONNECTED NEARLY TWO THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH WHO WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE WITH FUNDING FROM CDS
ACT AND PHILANTHROPY. SO NOT
ONLY DO OUR YOUTH NOW HAVE
ACCESS TO RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS THEY'RE USING IT
PILOT PARTICIPANTS USE THEIR
PHONES FOR COMMUNICATIONS WITH
FRIENDS FAMILY AND SUPPORT. FOR
THE SCHOOLWORK EMPLOYMENT AND
TELEHEALTH 1100% OF
PARTICIPANTS AND FOSTER YOUTH
SERVING AGENCIES BELIEVE THIS
PROGRAM SHOULD BE CONTINUED.
WHICH IS WHY WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT. WHILE THE CPUC DOES
HER PURVIEW OVER THIS PILOT THE
VIEWS ARE WARDS OF THE STATE
AND IT IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
AS LEGISLATORS TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR RIGHTS TO COMMUNICATION
AT. THE BOTTOM OF CALIFORNIA
FOSTER CARE BILL OF RIGHTS I
REALIZED THIS PROGRAM IS THE
ONLY PROGRAM THAT THE PHILS
THERE RIGHT INCLUSIVELY AND
EQUITABLY. YOUR SUPPORT IS
REQUIRED TO ENSURE THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUES WITH NO SERVICE GAPS.
WELL WE ARE THRILLED WITH
COMMISSIONER SHARON MUST
PROPOSED DECISION ON JUNE
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A DEFINITIVE
DECISION NOR COULD IT BUY PLANS
FOR HOW THE PILOT WILL BECOME A
PERMANENT LIFELINE PROGRAM.
THIS WILL TAKE TIME AND EFFORT
FROM THE CPC. TO DESIGN. THANKS
FOR PUBLIC COME AND TIME TO
OPEN AN ECHO OUR- PROCESS FOR
BOTH TELECOM. AND IT MAY
CANDIDATE. NO WORK HAS YET BEEN
DONE- PERMANENCY FOR THIS
PROGRAM. FURTHER THERE WERE NO
THERE WAS NO A COMPARTMENT OR
BOARD BUDGET. ARE BAD FOR THE
PILOT. IN PARTICULAR A PLAN FOR
SWAPPING OUT PHONES WHICH MUST
HAPPEN BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
BECAUSE T. MOBILE IS SHUTTING
DOWN THE SPRINT NETWORK HAS YET
TO BE REALIZED WELL THE C. P.
U. C. T. MOBILE AND I FOSTER
HAPPY WORKING ON PLANS ON
BUDGET. DECISION ISN'T EXPECTED
UNTIL JULY FIFTEENTH WHEN THE
COMMISSION VOTE LEAVING ONLY
FIVE AND A HALF MONTHS TO SWAP
OUT. FIFTEEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND TIME IS
RUNNING OUT AND WE CANNOT
AFFORD ANY DELAYS ON JANUARY
FIRST FIFTEEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN DR USED
PHONE BOOKS FEES TO FUNCTION.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
FOSTER CARE COMMUNITY THE I
THOUGHT THE PHONE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
SUCCESS. BUT THERE IS A RISK
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA THANK LOSE
ALL THEIR COMMUNICATION GAINES.
DO YOU THINK SERVICE CAN HAVE
DIRE CONSEQUENCES AS ONE NEW
PARTICIPANT SHARED I MIGHT HAVE
COMMITTED SUICIDE IF I WASN'T
ABLE TO REACH MY SUPPORT SYSTEM
WITH BUY I FOSTER FROM. FORTY
THREE CENTS BY FOSTER IN OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS IN CHILD
BALLPARK SUPPORT SB FIVE FORTY
SIX AND RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND HAVE- ONE PRIME WILL
AND- TO TESTIFY BY PHONE-
MISTER HEARD. WITH TURN. IF THE
MODERATE WOULD HELP PLEASE- TO
GET MR AND IS ON THE PHONE.
RENDON YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK
YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
NASSAR HERNANDEZ I'LL BE HAPPY
TO TURN DOZEN MEMBERS-
CERVANTES THANK THE AUTHOR-
SABINE'S GULL FORWARDED FOR
ACCOUNT ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
TAKEN STEPS TO HELP FOSTER
YOUTH WE ARE IN AGREEMENT ON
THE PRINCIPLE OF HELPING FOLKS
USE IN ANY WAY THAT WE CAN- AND
I ALSO WANT TO GO OUT THERE
STAFF TO WORKING WITH HIM ON.
SOME AMENDMENTS- IN FOR HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH US- WE'RE AT
RIGHT NOW IS THAT TURN IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED
DECISION HE QC ONLY BELIEVES.
THE POST. AFTER THAT THAT WOULD.
SOME OF THE ISSUES AND ABSOLUTE
OF THESE ISSUES UNTIL. I'VE BE
POSSIBLE IS CURRENTLY ESTABLISH
WITH THEM A LIFELINE PRO. AND
SO. WE COULD AFTER HOPE WHICH
LIKE- ARE NOT IF THIS BILL WITH
THE NEXT. BEYOND THAT THERE IS
SOME CLASSIC THAT WE WILL TO
TRY TO MAKE WITH THE AUTHOR.
I'M NOT REGARDING BENEFITS
DEFINITION I WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PLUS YOU RECEIVE THE
MAXIMUM. BENEFIT. WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT HAS DROPPED. IT
MAY RESULT IN ACTUALLY- LAST-
BENEFIT FOR SPONSORING CONTENT
WITH CRITICAL PEOPLE. AND
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCE WE NEED
TO TAKE NOT LANGUAGE UP AND
WILL CONTINUE DISCUSS THAT WITH
THE DOCTOR. WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. POLICIES HAVE.
MUCH ACCESS AS MANY PROVIDERS
ARE AVAILABLE. ON THIS
CURRENTLY B. THE PILOT PROJECT
IT'S ALWAYS GOING WOULD HAVE TO
COVER EVERYONE. AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE TO ANSWER TOUGH
ALL. AND WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE
RESOURCES OF THE PROVIDERS
THEMSELVES TO OFFER HAVE YOU
QUIT MEANT TO FOSTER YOU-
THERE'S POTENTIAL HERE. WHERE
HE PROVIDERS WILL NOT HAVE TO
PAY A PROVIDE EQUIPMENT STELLAR
INSTEAD WILL COME OUT OF- GREAT
PLAYER- FUNDS. AND SO WE WANTED
TO PROTECT THAT WOULD THAT'S
GOOD FOR EVERYONE WE CAN DETECT
THAT REPAIR FUNDS. I CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE TO PROVIDE. I
ISSUED MAN. DO NOT CALL. SO THE
WITHIN THE PUBLIC AT SIXTY- AND
WE'RE TO WITH THE AUTHOR I'M
GOING FOR HIM THANK THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF WORKING WITH US AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
FOR THANK YOU MUCH OF. THE
NUMBER MOVE ON A PUBLIC COMMENT.
MIND EVERY IT'S STATE YOUR NAME
ORGAN. AND ONLY. IF THERE'S ANY
OF SUPPORT OR- WITNESS IN THE
CHAIN. NOT SEEING ANY HOUR
MOVIE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE R.
T. S. HOWEVER THE MODERATOR LET
US KNOW IF THERE'S ANY SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FORTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO PRINT SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE FOUR
SIX AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN THE PARKS.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO A LINE OF
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL OF THE
RECORDS WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTOR TO FIFTY SHOULDN'T
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU I'M GOING TO BE
QUESTIONS FROM KITTERY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELL THE
FIRST. SO WE HAVE- THAT IS
CORRECT I APOLOGIZE FOR THE WE
HAD WELL WE HAVE A THIRD AND
FOURTH. I KNOW HIM BUT- MISTER
WILK AT THE CLOSE SURE I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO
TESTIFIED BOTH PRO AND CON AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK RETURN
WE'VE WE'VE COME A LONG WAY ON
THIS BILL WE ALL WANT THE SAME
THING I'M SURE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
COME TO A SUCCESSFUL
CONCLUSION. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION- MISTER WILL TO
OUR ACCEPT ANY AMENDMENT HAVE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THIS MONTH
THE MOTION WOULD BE DO PASSED.
WITH A COMMITMENT AMENDED AND
HUMAN SERVICES- MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE FOUR SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
COMMITMENTS TAKE AMENDMENTS AND
HUMAN SERVICES SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HI BOERNER HORVATH.
BRIAN BRENT HI BENNETT. BENNETT
I DAVIES DAVIS I EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN HELLO HI HELLO. HELLO HI
SILVA. QUICKSILVER I RODRIGUEZ.
VALLADARES LOADERS I WEBER
WEBER HI. I IS TEN NO ZERO THAT
BILLS ON CALL REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
THIS CONCLUDES BILL
PRESENTATIONS FOR TODAY SO NOW
WE WILL RE OPEN OUR ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS- IN THE INTEREST
OF GETTING THOSE MEMBERS- TO
THEIR NEXT SCHEDULED
APPOINTMENT WILL OPEN IT UP A
COUPLE TIMES OR THE START NOW
IF YOU IF YOU MEANT IF YOU CAN
MEN SECRETARY. HI I'M NUMBER
ONE SB SEVEN FOUR THREE. TO
PASS THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY.
DEVELOPMENT ITEM NUMBER THREE.
SB FIVE EIGHT NINE TO PASS A
TRANSPORTATION. BENNETT BENNETT
I. EDUARDO GARCIA. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I HELLO HELLO I KIRK
SILVA. QUICKSILVER I. IS ELEVEN
KNOWS ZERO. BEVELS ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO. SB TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION. BOERNER HORVATH
HELLO HELLO HI. AYE AYES NINE
NOES ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL. I
AM NUMBER FOUR SB THREE FOUR
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
BOERNER HORVATH HELLO HELLO HI.
THAT'S IS TWELVE NO ZERO HAVE
BILLS ON CALL. I REMEMBER FIVE.
SB FIVE FOUR SIX. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH THE COMMITMENT TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS AND HUMAN
SERVICES. BOERNER HORVATH
EDUARDO GARCIA. RODRIGUEZ. HIS
TENDERS ERA THAT BILLS ON CALL.
YEAH IN SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
WE'RE
GOOD YEAH.
B. AS A WINDOWS THE-
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS. THIS AND
WE'RE ALL WE ALL GO THROUGH THE
SAME THING.
I AM NUMBER ONE
ITEM NUMBER THREE ON CONSENT.
SB SEVEN FOUR THREE SB FIVE
EIGHT NINE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I. I AM NUMBER
TWO SB TWENTY EIGHT. THE MOTION
AS THE PASSES AMENDED TO
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT VOTING. IS
NINE. NO ZERO. THAT BILLS ON
CALL ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB THREE
FOUR ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I. IS THIRTEEN
OH ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. THE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE FOUR
SIX THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
WITH THE COMMITMENTS TAKEN IN
MINUTES AND HUMAN SERVICES.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I. EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I. RODRIGUEZ. IS TWELVE
NO ZERO. THAT BILLS ON CALL.
FIRST. CONSENT ITEMS. SB SEVEN
FOUR THREE SB FIVE EIGHT NINE.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I.
HIS TWELVE NO ZERO THAT BILLS
ON CALL. I REMEMBER TO SB.
TWENTY EIGHT. AYE AYES NINE
NOES ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB. THREE FOUR
ONE. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
MERCHANTS THE MANAGEMENT. THAT
BILL IS OUT. I DON'T NUMBER
FIVE SB FIVE FOUR SIX. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH A
COMMITMENT TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
AND HUMAN SERVICES. RODRIGUEZ.
HIS TWELVE NO ZERO THAT BILLS
ON CALL.